i don't take credit for anything i am
all my accolades i'm like my parents my
circumstance oh soviet russia to america
oh the 80s oh jersey you get into all
these circumstances which helps them get
the insight to create affirmation to
create lack of fear to try something to
start the process to get to a happier
place that is a [ __ ] blessing
now i want people to figure out that
things are right for them based on their
luck circumstance yes maybe they're not
an entrepreneur because they don't have
incredible lack of fear but maybe that
they are incredibly compassionate
unbelievably analytical wonderfully
funny like let's lean into what we're
[ __ ] awesome about everybody's
spending all their time on what they
suck at themselves they're doing that
and i promise you everybody else is
spending all their time telling you what
you suck at i'm spending all my time
thinking about what i'm [ __ ] awesome
at and i'm spending all my time trying
to figure out what everybody else is
awesome at
you